>>> FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
NOW TRYING TO DENY HE CALLED TO
TERMINATE THE CONSTITUTION DAYS
AFTER HE CALLED TO TERMINATE THE
CONSTITUTION.
TRUMP IN A POST ON HIS WEBSITE
TRUTH SOCIAL IS BLAMING THE
MEDIA FOR USING HIS EXACT WORDS
THAT DESPITE HIS POST SUGGESTING
THE TERMINATION OF THE
CONSTITUTION REMAIN ONLINE.
ON SATURDAY, HE WROTE, QUOTE, A
MASSIVE FRAUD OF THIS TYPE AND
MAGNITUDE ALLOWS FOR THE
TERMINATION OF ALL RULES,
REGULATIONS AND ARTICLES, EVEN
THOSE FOUND IN THE CONSTITUTION.
AFTER DAYS OF SILENCE, SEVERAL
TOP REPUBLICANS HAVE NOW
CONDEMNED TRUMP'S COMMENTS.
>> I MUST TELL YOU THAT I THINK
EVERYONE THAT SERVES IN PUBLIC
OFFICE, EVERYONE THAT ASPIRES TO
SERVE OR SERVE AGAIN SHOULD MAKE
IT CLEAR WE WILL SUPPORT AND
DEFEND THE CONSTITUTION OF THE
UNITED STATES.
>> I DISAGREE WITH THE
PRESIDENT.
THE CONSTITUTION CAN BE AMENDED.
THE CONSTITUTION CAN BE
INTERPRETED.
BUT THE CONSTITUTION CAN'T BE
SUSPENDED.
>> THE REPUBLICAN PARTY HAS LONG
BEEN THE PARTY OF THE
CONSTITUTION.
AND SO WHEN PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYS
HE WANTS TO SUSPEND THE
CONSTITUTION, HE GOES FROM BEING
MAGA TO BEING RINO.
WE'RE THE CONSTITUTION PARTY.
>> AND THAT CAME AFTER THEY WERE
ASKED BY REPORTERS TO RESPOND TO
TRUMP'S COMMENTS AND WHILE SOME
HAVE SPOKEN OUT FORCEFULLY, LIKE
SENATORS LISA MURKOWSKI, MIKE
ROUNDS, OTHERS ARE STAYED
SILENT.
SOME LIKE ROGER MARSHALL SAY
THEY DON'T THINK IT IS A
RELEVANT QUESTION THEY SHOULD BE
ASKED ABOUT.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP SAID ABOUT THE
CONSTITUTION.
I JUST DON'T THINK THAT'S THE
ISSUE.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S WHAT YOU
ALL SHOULD BE TALKING ABOUT.
>> SENATOR MINORITY LEADER MITCH
McCONNELL IS EXPECTED TO ADDRESS
WHAT TRUMP SAID TODAY, BUT
JOINING US NOW IS TRUMP'S
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISER JOHN
BOLTON, ALSO THE AMBASSADOR TO
THE UNITED NATIONS AND GOOD
MORNING, AMBASSADOR.
I'VE SEEN YOUR RESPONSE TO THIS,
WHAT YOU'VE BEEN SAYING ABOUT
TRUMP'S CALLS TO TERMINATE THE
CONSTITUTION.
DO YOU THINK IT SHOULD BE
DISQUALIFYING FOR A PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE IF THEY MADE COMMENTS
LIKE THIS?
>> WELL, OF COURSE IT IS
DISQUALIFYING.
YOU KNOW, THE PRESIDENT TAKES AN
OATH OF OFFICE PRESCRIBED BY THE
CONSTITUTION ITSELF THAT SAYS HE
WILL TO THE BEST OF HIS ABILITY
PRESERVE, PROTECT AND DEFEND THE
CONSTITUTION.
TRUMP HIMSELF TOOK THAT OATH.
AND EFFECTIVELY HE'S NOW SAYING
HE DIDN'T MEAN IT.
AND IF GOD, FORBID, HE WERE EVER
ELECTED AND TOOK THE OATH AGAIN,
WE COULDN'T TRUST HE WOULD ABIDE
BY THOSE WORDS.
I THINK THIS IS EXISTENTIAL.
AND EVEN BEYOND BEING A MATTER
OF HIGH PRINCIPLE, WHICH I THINK
IT IS, AS A MATTER OF PRACTICAL
POLITICS, THAT STATEMENT EVEN AS
HE FAILED TO TRY AND CORRECT IT
OVER THE WEEKEND, THAT STATEMENT
IS A TIME BOMB SITTING ON THE
DESK OF EVERY REPUBLICAN MEMBER
OF THE HOUSE AND THE SENATE,
EVERY REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE
AROUND THE COUNTRY.
IF WE DON'T VERY CLEARLY, VERY
SOON, UNEQUIVOCALLY REJECT IT,
NAMING TRUMP BY NAME, THIS WILL
COME BACK TO HAUNT US IN
NOVEMBER OF 2024 IN WAYS WE CAN
ONLY IMAGINE.
>> DO YOU REALLY EXPECT
REPUBLICANS WILL DO THAT,
THOUGH?
>> I EXPECT THAT IF ENOUGH
PEOPLE SPEAK OUT THAT OTHERS
WILL FOLLOW.
I THINK ACROSS THE COUNTRY IF
YOU ASK REPUBLICANS AND
REPUBLICAN-LEANING INDEPENDENTS
WHICH IS MORE IMPORTANT, DONALD
TRUMP OR THE CONSTITUTION, THEY
WOULD OVERWHELMINGLY SAY
APPROXIMATING 100% WOULD SAY THE
CONSTITUTION.
IT IS THE FAILURE OF LEADERS TO
STAND UP AND OPPOSE THIS KIND OF
RHETORIC THAT EMPOWERS TRUMP.
AND IT WILL BE AN ISSUE.
THERE IS NO DOUBT ABOUT IT.
I THINK THE NOVEMBER 8
CONGRESSIONAL ELECTIONS PROVE
THAT POINT.
DONALD TRUMP IS THE BEST ASSET
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS.
>> DO YOU WISH THAT YOU HAD
STOOD UP SOONER?
>> LOOK, I LASTED FOR 17 MONTHS,
I DID THE BEST THAT I COULD, I'M
SURE I MADE PLENTY OF MISTAKES,
BUT THE ONLY THING YOU CAN SAY
IS YOU GOT TO TRY AND DO THE
BEST YOU COULD.
I WROTE WHAT I HOPE IS A PRETTY
DEFINITIVE ACCOUNT OF MY TIME
THERE, BOTH FOR THE GENERAL
PUBLIC TO READ NOW AND FOR
HISTORY TO HELP JUDGE FROM.
>> LET ME READ SOMETHING YOU
WROTE IN YOUR BOOK, BECAUSE
THERE WAS -- YOU DID TALK ABOUT
IT IN YOUR BOOK.
YOU HAVE SPOKEN ABOUT THIS
BEFORE.
AND IT SAYS ONE HIGHLIGHT CAME,
THIS IS WHAT YOU WERE TALKING
ABOUT, THE CONTEXT HERE, THAT
TRUMP MADE THE COMMENTS DURING A
DECEMBER 2018 DINNER WITH XI
JINPING, IN BUENOS AIRES, AND IT
SAYS ONE HIGHLIGHT CAME WHEN XI
SAID HE WANTED TO WORK WITH
TRUMP FOR SIX MORE YEARS, TRUMP
REPLAYED THAT PEOPLE WERE SAYING
THAT THE TWO-TERM CONSTITUTIONAL
LIMIT ON PRESIDENTS SHOULD BE
REPEALED FOR HIM AND THEN YOU
WENT ON TO WRITE THAT XI SAID
THE U.S. HAD TOO MANY ELECTIONS
BECAUSE HE DIDN'T WANT TO SWITCH
AWAYED NO NODDINGLY
APPROVED.
HE WANTED TO SUBVERT THE
CONSTITUTION SO HE COULD RUN
AGAIN, RUN FOR AS LONG AS HE
WANTED.
THAT'S A PRIME EXAMPLE OF
WANTING TO -- BY THE WAY, THE
TERM THAT -- I THINK THE
LAWMAKERS ARE GETTING IT WRONG,
THEY'RE SAYING HE WANTS TO
SUSPEND THE CONSTITUTION.
TRUMP SAID HE WANTED TO
TERMINATE THE CONSTITUTION, BUT
GO ON, PLEASE.
>> RIGHT, WELL, AT LEAST THERE
HE SAID AMEND THE CONSTITUTION,
HE'S NOW GIVEN UP ANY PRETENSE
AND THAT'S WHY I THINK THAT THE
COMMENT ABOUT TERMINATING THE
CONSTITUTION IS EXISTENTIAL.
THERE IS SIMPLY NO WAY TO WAFFLE
ON IT AND TO SAY MAYBE TRUMP
WON'T BE THE NOMINEE, MAYBE IT
IS NOT AN ISSUE NOW, IT IS AN
ISSUE.
AND THE -- IT IS JUST
UNACCEPTABLE FOR A PARTY AND A
CONSTITUTIONAL SYSTEM TO ACCEPT
AS ANYTHING ANY KIND OF LEADER
IN THAT PARTY, SOMEBODY WHO
OPPOSES THE CONSTITUTION THAT
UNDERLIES IT.
AND I THINK IF WE DON'T SPEAK UP
AND MAKE THAT CLEAR NOW, WE'RE
GOING TO REGRET IT.
THAT'S WHY I SAID I WOULD
CONTEMPLATE GETTING INTO THE
2024 RACE MYSELF, IF OTHERS
DON'T STEP UP TO IT.
THIS IS A MATTER OF HIGH
PRINCIPLE, BUT IT IS ALSO
SELF-INTEREST FOR THE PARTY, AND
IT STUNS ME THAT SO MANY PEOPLE
DON'T SEE THAT.
>> YOU WOULD SAY YOU WOULD
CONSIDER GETTING INTO IT.
IF YOU LOOK -- WHENEVER IT IS
POLITICALLY EXPEDIENT, PEOPLE
WILL PUT OUT STATEMENTS RIGHT
AWAY, RIGHT, AND ALTHOUGH THERE
HAVE BEEN SOME IN THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY WHO ARE SPEAKING OUT, NOT
ENOUGH, AND NOT CLEARLY AND NOT
IN A LOUD MANNER, AND I'LL JUST
REPEAT, THEY'RE SAYING SUSPEND
THE CONSTITUTION.
HE SAID TERMINATE THE
CONSTITUTION.
ONE LAWMAKER THERE SAYING THAT'S
NOT SOMETHING WE SHOULD BE
TALKING ABOUT.
THAT'S NOT FOR HIM TO DETERMINE
WHAT WE SHOULD BE TALKING ABOUT
AT THIS MOMENT.
AT WHAT POINT WILL YOU DECIDE
YOU WANT TO GET IN BECAUSE I
DON'T SEE A WHOLE, YOU KNOW,
FORCE OF REPUBLICANS WHO ARE
GOING TO COME OUT AND CONDEMN
DONALD TRUMP FOR THIS, LET ALONE
ANYTHING, ESPECIALLY COMING
AFTER WHAT HAPPENED WITH THE
DINNER AT MAR-A-LAGO WITH
ANTISEMITES.
>> A LONG LIST OF OBJECTIONABLE
BEHAVIOR BY TRUMP.
I DON'T HAVE A SPECIFIC
TIMETABLE.
I THINK PEOPLE ARE IN A POSITION
NOW, HOWEVER, WHERE THE
PRESIDENTIAL -- THE FIELD OF
PRESIDENTIAL CONTENDERS IS IN
CO-ATE.
THERE IS A CHANCE TO SHAPE THE
FIELD AND THE DEBATE.
AND I'M VERY INTERESTED IN DOING
THAT.
I WOULD LIKE TO GET ON TO REAL
ISSUES LIKE NATIONAL SECURITY
THREATS TO THE UNITED STATES,
AND GET DONALD TRUMP BEHIND US.
BUT UNLESS ENOUGH REPUBLICANS
ARE WILLING TO STAND UP AND DO
THAT, IT IS NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
AND, BY THE WAY, WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT, IT WON'T BE THE MEDIA
CRITICISM OF DONALD TRUMP THAT
TAKES HIM OUT, AND IT WON'T BE
CRITICISM BY THE DEMOCRATS.
ULTIMATELY REPUBLICANS HAVE TO
DO THIS.
NOW IS THE TIME TO DO IT.
>> 100% ON THAT.
>> CAN I ASK YOU ABOUT, BEFORE
YOU GO, THOSE NATIONAL SECURITY
THREATS TO THE UNITED STATES AND
TO THE WORLD, WHILE WE HAVE YOU,
AMBASSADOR, AND LET'S START WITH
IRAN.
I WONDER IF YOU AGREE WITH
FORMER SECRETARY OF STATE
HILLARY CLINTON WHO SAID ON CNN
LAST WEEK THE U.S. SHOULD NOT IN
ANY WAY BE NEGOTIATING WITH IRAN
ON ANYTHING RIGHT NOW.
INCLUDING ON THE NUCLEAR
AGREEMENT.
YOU'VE BEEN SO CLEAR ABOUT YOUR
POSITION ON IRAN, YOU WROTE IN
AUGUST THAT ANY NEGOTIATIONS
ENCOURAGE TERRORIST ACTIVITIES.
SOUNDS LIKE YOU TWO ARE ON THE
SAME PAGE?
>> WELL, HILLARY CLINTON SEES
THE LIGHT.
I'M DELIGHTED THAT'S HER
POSITION.
THAT'S THE CORRECT DECISION.
I WISH JOE
ARTICULATE IT.
>> ON RUSSIA, I WOULD LIKE TO
PLAY FOR YOU WHAT ANTONY BLINKEN
SAID ABOUT ANY POTENTIAL QUOTE,
UNQUOTE OFF RAMP FOR RUSSIA IN
THE WAR ON UKRAINE.
LET'S PLAY THAT AND GET YOUR
THOUGHTS.
>> ONE OF THE THINGS YOU CAN
IMAGINE IS THE RUSSIANS TRYING
TO FIND AN OFF RAMP THAT WOULD
BE A PHONY OFF RAMP.
LET'S HAVE A CEASE-FIRE, LET'S
FREEZE THINGS IN PLACE, GET A
FROZEN CONFLICT, NEVER NEGOTIATE
ABOUT THE TERRITORY THAT THEY
HAVE SEIZED, AND CONTINUE TO
HOLD, REST, REFIT, REGROUP,
REATTACK.
>> DO YOU SHARE THE CONCERN OF
THE CURRENT SECRETARY OF STATE?
>> SURE.
I WROTE OP-EDS TO THAT EFFECT IN
AUGUST AND SEPTEMBER, PREDICTING
THAT'S WHAT PUTIN WOULD DO.
AND IF HE HAD BEEN WELL ADVISED,
HE WOULD HAVE DONE IT BACK IN
SEPTEMBER BECAUSE HE CAN'T DO IT
NOW.
THE ONLY OFF RAMP FOR RUSSIA IN
UKRAINE I THINK WAS VERY WELL
ARTICULATED BY THE PRIME
MINISTER OF FINLAND, SEVERAL
WEEKS AGO.
SHE SAID HOW DOES THIS END?
IT ENDS WHEN RUSSIAN TROOPS
LEAVE UKRAINE.
THAT'S HOW IT ENDS.
>> YEAH.
>> CAN I ASK ONE MORE QUESTION
BEFORE WE LET YOU GO ON YOU
SAYING YOU'RE MULLING A 2024
RUN.
WERE YOU CONSIDERING THAT BEFORE
TRUMP TWEETED ON SATURDAY OR
TRUMP SAID EN SATURDAY THAT THE
CONSTITUTION SHOULD BE
TERMINATED?
>> NO, YOU KNOW, I LOOKED AT IT
VERY SERIOUSLY IN 2016.
I WENT TO THE CATTLE SHOWS IN
IOWA AND NEW HAMPSHIRE.
ULTIMATELY DECIDED NOT TO.
AND I DIDN'T THINK I WOULD IN
THIS CYCLE.
BUT MY POINT REALLY IS THAT THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY HAS GOT TO STEP
UP TO THE MOMENT HERE AND IF I
CAN HELP PRECIPITATE THAT, THEN
I WOULD SERIOUSLY CONSIDER
GETTING IN.
AND I THINK SOMEBODY'S GOT TO DO
IT.